[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en las
últimas quiebras bancarias que han
puesto el jaque a la estabilidad del
sistema financiero para ello nos
acompañan en este estudio Jesús Castillo
economista investigador del grupo
natixis bienvenido Hola Elizabeth creció
es docente especializada en ética de los
negocios bienvenida Elizabeth Muchas
gracias mucho gusto y en dúples nos
acompaña Daniela Ordóñez es economista
jefe en Francia de la Oxford economics
bienvenida Daniela Buenos días gracias
por la invitación
la nueva crisis bancaria hoy nuestro
asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
el inicio fue la quiebra del silicon que
en Estados Unidos le siguió el colapso
de otros como siña turbank y las
necesidades de liquidez de First
Republic y luego continuó con el
derrumbe de Credit suiz que ha acabado
con su venta a vs son ya dos semanas de
sobresaltos en el sector bancario y con
miedo a un efecto contagio que pueda dar
lugar en el peor de los casos a otra
crisis financiera el mensaje más
repetido en estos momentos es el de la
llamada la calma de las propias
entidades y también de los bancos
centrales el dinero es miedoso y el
sistema está interconectado eso ya lo
sabíamos como también conocemos esa
injusta realidad de socializar pérdidas
porque hay riesgo y riesgo endémico
cuando siempre se privatizan los
beneficios biden ya avisó que esto no
iba a pasar esta vez Pero Qué riesgos
reales tiene este nuevo terremoto
bancario veamos algunas portadas que nos
deja la prensa diario le seco aquí en
Francia Suiza sumerge a Europa en una
tempes financiera El financial Times
califica de matrimonio a la fuerza la
compra de Credit swiss por parte del vs
provocando el miedo en los tenedores de
bonos de forma más genérica de economist
se pregunta en su portada qué está
ocurriendo con los bancos le traslado la
pregunta señor castillo qué está
ocurriendo con los bancos Así podríamos
responder de forma sencilla a la
pregunta de si estamos realmente ante
una gran crisis bancaria
a este punto de la crisis voy a decir
que no Y como están diciendo todos los
reguladores los bancos centrales no hace
falta
crear un pánico porque el problema está
ubicado en un banco regionales
americanos y luego en otro problema que
es bastante diferente en el credisfit en
Suiza y entonces las causas de estas dos
de estos dos problemas bancarios son
diferentes por un lado Suiza por el otro
los bancos americanos pero no a mí me
parece que de momento no estamos ante
una crisis financiera mayor claro el
origen de este terremoto bancario el
primer caso fue el del silicon pero se
nos dijo que era un caso especial por su
tamaño pequeño y debido a una mala
gestión vamos a explicar este caso en
origen porque un caso que parecía tan
delimitado Elizabeth de una mala gestión
Al final nos ha puesto en temor a todo
el sistema
Es que yo creo que la
palabra clave es la confianza es que de
ir de empezar con un banco regional que
quiebra pues ha creado desconfianza en
el sistema y para la gente que no
conocían las finanzas para el la persona
londa pues no entiende las poblaciones
en el sistema bancario porque es muy
complejo y esta complejidad pues crea
incertidumbre crea preguntas y la gente
no sabe cómo explicar entonces Más allá
de los investigadores inversores que
conoce bien conocen bien el sistema
inversores institucionales
las personas los inversores como tú y yo
pues hay gente que no sabe y entonces
enfrentando este miedo de no poder sacar
el dinero pues se crea este pánico la
gente se va al banco es lo que llamamos
efecto pues la gente se va y reclama el
depósito ahora bien yo comparto la
opinión de colega que no es un terremoto
son dos asuntos que para mí son
independientes uno del otro en la mesura
en que pues al inicio Hay un problema de
gestión Hay un problema de
comportamiento individual y de decisión
individual de Los Altos ejecutivos de
los bancos bien sea el banco regional en
California como el y entonces pues si
hubo una si se hizo una malgamo entre
los dos no quiere decir por nada que el
sistema está quebrando al revés lo que
hemos visto desde el 2008 la última
crisis Es que la reglamentación La
regulación pues se incrementó con mucha
inteligencia se decidió por haccios de
incrementarlos la resistencia a la
insolvencia de los bancos con más
capitales con más fondos propios de los
bancos de incremento Hasta el 8% de los
activos ponderados de riesgo Así que eso
parece mucho mejor se trata también de
aumentar la solvencia entonces de los
bancos la liquidez
y también hubo otras herramientas como
reducir o limitar el apalancamiento que
pueden la deuda que pueden tomar los
bancos dos relacionen capital propio
fondo propios y deuda y también un
sistema se puso se implementó un sistema
que permite gestionar la crisis de
manera ordenada Así que todos estos
todas estas herramientas y decisiones
nuevas reglas permiten de tener más
estabilidad financiera Sí pero vemos que
las palabras contagio pánico confianza
sobre todo confianza es la amalgama ese
pegamento que hace que funcione el
sistema y que el tópico de que el dinero
es miedoso no es tan tópico Jesús No
pero
lo que dice Elizabeth es muy ahí la
percepción que tiene el inversor y luego
la realidad A diferencia de lo que pasó
en 2008 que
los bancos estaban interconectados con
liquidez con el mercado interbancario
donde cada banco prestaba al otro
etcétera hoy en día eso es totalmente
cambiado la liquidez casi viene toda de
los bancos centrales Así que hoy no hay
una interconexión tan grande que puede
provocar la caída así en dominó de toda
la les voy a preguntar después por la
conexión de esta realidad con las
políticas de lucha contra la inflación
que tenemos actualmente tenemos a
distancia Daniel Ordoñez que es
economista jefa en la de Francia en la
Oxford economics París Y a partir del
caso de Credit swis también le quiero
preguntar Daniela ha habido contagio de
los casos de Estados Unidos a Europa
Cuál es la urgencia de del gobierno
suizo en salvadores tabaco primero que
es grande que puede colapsar que puede
colapsar la economía Suiza y alrededor y
sobre todo el objetivo es delimitar esta
pérdida de confianza es decir que entre
entre lo que pasó en ese bebé en Estados
Unidos y la la pérdida de valor de la
acción de concretamente no pasó mucho
para el hubieron ciertos eventos como
uno de los mayores inversores que dijo
que no iba a dar más más capital al
banco pero en sí no hubieron más
escándalos o más problemas que
justifiquen esta caída realmente
solamente una caída de confianza una
pérdida de confianza masiva de la parte
de los inversores del mercado financiero
hasta ese valor es decir que es un
contagio no un contagio de una situación
muy mala en un banco específico regional
americano que
por fragilidad del otro banco se
contagia y se amplifique en este banco
Entonces el objetivo del banco suizo y
del Banco Central europeo es de mantener
o de contener este contagio Sí está bien
Estamos perdiendo confianza por el
momento en entidades bancarias que de
todos modos estaban un poco frágiles
entonces pueden ser de cierta manera ser
justificado pero lo más importante es
que este pánico no se no se no se vaya
no se contagie al resto del sistema
bancario
la bancarrota de silicon Valley nos hizo
recordar enseguida todos nos fuimos a
2008 no pero yo no sé hasta qué punto
estas dos crisis son comparables porque
no es el mismo tamaño que el imán
Brothers ni tampoco tiene el mismo
problema de activos tóxicos entiendo
Elizabeth sí sí no hay los activos
tóxicos como había no habían pero al
inicio
Pero por otra parte hubo problemas de
ética en el 2008 que vemos aquí al nivel
de Los Altos ejecutivos como decía antes
de nuevo en la silicona y en el hubo un
problema enorme de gobernancia la
gobernanza de Freddy swiss pues se
involucró en cosas de corrupción
Fiscales para sistemas de cocaína
también exactamente entonces una
acumulación que facilitó el banco al
inicio Más allá de lo que decía antes de
reglamentación regulación reglas
estándares todo lo hicieron muy bien en
el comité el comisionado de basileo 3
muy bien pero más allá de esta
alimentación Hay un problema de ética e
individual y de decisión individuales
como como se regula este riesgo moral yo
diría de Los Altos ejecutivos que
deciden como lo hemos visto en el
silicon Valley por una un desequilibrio
que crearon las decisiones crearon
desequilibrio del balance entre
con este banco cómo se regula estas
decisiones mejor y cómo se puede
responsabilizar los ejecutivos
antes de que pase algunas crisis así
entonces Más allá de la reglamentación
es un problema de ética y de decisión
las políticas de lucha monetaria contra
la inflación Qué relación guardan con
esta crisis muestran no sé que son
peligrosas y no se limitan que tienen
que ejercerse con bisturí y Jesús
Cristina lagar presidenta del Banco
Central europeo avisado de que rebajar
la inflación es innegociable pero no
desvela tampoco si seguirá subiendo los
tipos ante las turbulencias Cómo hay que
encajar este tipo de mensajes Bueno lo
que dice que es sin la lucha contra la
inflación es la prioridad del Banco
Central europeo pero como muchos bancos
centrales tiene dos prioridades dos
objetivos la estabilidad financiera
también que tampoco es innegociable dice
no vamos a arbitrar entre inflación y
estabilidad financiera los tipos de
intereses sirven para controlar la
inflación Y entonces nosotros por lo
menos en la crisis pensamos que van a
seguir subiendo tipo Es una herramienta
útil pero hay que utilizarla con cuidado
entiendo hay que utilizarla para lo que
sirve Sí y luego está la cuestión de la
estabilidad financiera y entonces ahí
hay otra otras herramientas que puede
movilizar un Banco Central aportando
liquidez etcétera Y entonces ahí está El
dilema lo que pasa es que cuando un
Banco Central Sube los tipos de
intereses Pues tiende a devaluar el
valor de los activos de los bancos de
los bonos de los bonos de estado y ahí
está el problema es que a corto plazo si
quieres más liquidez pérdidas pérdida
Pero
todo es una cuestión de temporalidad
a largo plazo la subida de los tipos de
intereses es bueno para los bancos ganan
más dinero pero está el periodo de
transición donde ahí sí pueden aparecer
riesgos que lo que le ha pasado al
silicon Ya ven que estamos consiguiendo
muchísimas pistas para entender la
crisis bancaria actual Vamos a continuar
con ello a vuelta de pausa aquí en
Primera Plana hasta ahora Gracias
reporteros el programa de reportajes de
France 24 descubra las historias de la
gente con nuestro reporteros por todo el
planeta
nuestros periodistas van donde ocurren
la noticia para contársela cada semana
reporteros le trae una historia inédita
no se la pierda
reporteros en France 24 y frans 24.com
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
hablando de la crisis bancaria que
estamos viviendo con varias quiebras
financieras estamos con Jesús Castillo
economista investigador del grupo
natixis Elizabeth greció docente
especializada en ética de los negocios y
a distancia nos acompaña Daniel Ordoñez
economista jefe de Francia de la Oxford
economics hablando de la relación de las
políticas antiinflación nos habíamos
quedado antes de la pausa con la actual
crisis bancaria Elizabeth Qué papel han
tenido las tasas de interés elevadas
Pues cuando una tasa está elevada Pues
el precio de los bonos es más matemático
pues baja el problema es que la silicón
tenía muchos bonos en sus activos más
del 50% cuando normalmente un banco
tiene no más de 25%
y pues una falta de diversificación si
podría decir en el activo del Así
que hubo directamente un impacto en la
la liquidez a disposición porque cuando
el banco quiso vender sus bonos pues se
despreciaron perdieron valor y entonces
faltaba la liquidez para poder hacer
frente a las reclamaciones de depósitos
de parte de las empresas de los clientes
que eran empresas de la del sector
tecnológico y entonces pues hubo una
oración directa en el caso de
en el es un poco diferente porque es más
una fragilidad sistema sistémica a nivel
del banco desde muchos años pues como
hemos dicho antes participó en varias
fraudes o errores de gestión que ahora
está pagando tenemos en dobles a Daniel
Ordoñez economista jefe de la Oxford
economics le pregunto con el aval del
gobierno suizo vs absorbió a Credit
swiss estamos hablando bueno Después de
palabras mayores y ante los temores de
un efecto dominó Christine lagar dice
estar dispuesta a sacar la artillería
pesada este tipo de escenario pone
nervioso al usuario de a pie que peor
que puede hacer sacar su dinero
una persona que tiene sus depósitos en
un banco europeo por el momento sí el
banco está bien manejado y tiene una
buena capitalización lo que en general
está garantizado por la supervisión del
Banco Central europeo del bce no tiene
mayor necesidad o mayor razón de
entrar en pánico y retirar sus sus
depósitos en el caso de que de que su
banco tenga problemas de liquidez El
Banco Central va está pues dispuesto a
intervenir para asegurar que los
depósitos se se puedan pagar de manera
normal y en caso de que realmente una
una
institución financiera está en un en una
situación crítica y que no tenga
suficiente dinero para para pagar los
depósitos el la garantía la garantía de
depósitos de la Unión Europea que
garantizas hasta mil euros de depósitos
a cada a cada a cada cuenta en cada en
cada banco pues ya garantiza una buena
parte es importante decir que muchas
herramientas se han construido desde la
crisis financiera desde la crisis de
deuda soberana Europea y que no estamos
en la misma situación de vulnerabilidad
Sí claro mucha gente se pregunta Jesús
si están seguros sus ahorros en el caso
de Estados Unidos creo que la garantía
de depósito Es mayor que en Europa en
España es de 100.000 euros por ejemplo
Entonces siempre se aconseja digamos que
a partir de esa cantidad se diversifique
no se pongan digamos los huevos en
distintas cestas no para salvaguardar
esos esos depósitos no Bueno sí 100.000
euros ya es muchísimo dinero para
tenerlo en una cuenta y estamos hablando
de cuenta corriente cuenta corriente
cuenta corriente que es muy importante
porque otros tipos de depósitos no van a
beneficiar de la misma garantía luego la
comparación con Estados Unidos en 250
mil dólares creo en Estados Unidos creo
que el monto es más elevado no
y luego en Estados Unidos en el caso de
la silicon lo depositarios eran
principalmente empresas que entonces no
benefician de los mismos la garantía que
el ciudadano de a O sea que como ha
dicho Daniela si hoy cualquier europeo
de la clase media digamos no tiene por
qué tener miedo de mantener su depósitos
en los principales bancos europeos que
todos están muy bien capitalizados e
incluso si cogemos el caso de Suiza que
no hace parte de la Unión Europea pero
ningún depositante ha perdido dinero en
la fusión que está habiendo que están
haciendo hoy con
lo dicho Daniela la tangencialmente como
muchas herramientas del sistema se han
ido perfeccionando a partir de otro
episodio que vivimos aquí en Europa muy
traumático aquella crisis de la deuda
soberana de 2008 y como esas
herramientas han ido haciendo más sólido
el sistema entiendo Elizabeth es lo que
decía antes hubo hubo medidas que se
tomaron en términos de solvencia de
aparcamiento de liquidez de sistema de
resolución de crisis Pero hay una un
paradoxo ahí
por ejemplo es una hora no justo ahora
en Europa y los bancos son más sólidos
como decía mi colega no no hay duda no
hay duda Pero a la misma vez estamos
creando un tipo de monstruo si me
explico si vemos el caso de hubiese
hay una Cómo se dice una huida en
adelante Sí porque estamos
complexificando la reglamentación La
regulación los estándares Por una parte
para proteger el sistema y hace algo más
estable
resiliente Pero por otra parte creamos
bancos siempre con este movimiento de
concentración de instituciones
financieras siempre más grandes siempre
más sistémicos hay unos 30 bancos en el
mundo que se llaman bancos sistémicos
que pues
traen un riesgo un riesgo sistémico
entonces aquí hay un pajaroso porque
estamos creando más siempre más
complejidad y se puede dudar de al final
si de verdad concentración
exactamente Al final controlamos todo
incluso sí como digo el sistema está más
resistente Por qué Porque este
movimiento de concentración la teoría de
la resiliencia dice que necesitamos
diversidad necesitamos compartimentos y
se puede pedir preguntar si estos
compartimentos que permiten de localizar
los riesgos están lo suficiente o no
comparte esta visión por un lado más
tranquilidad respecto a esas
herramientas creadas a partir de la
deuda de 2008 pero a partir de ahí las
incertidumbres que nos estaba contando
Elizabeth de esas de esa concentración
bancaria
Pues sí porque Cuanto más concentración
más dificultades luego de venir
a ayudar un banco lo que me parece
importante también decir que en el caso
de los bancos americanos había una
concentración de en el lado del activo
con muchos bonos del tesoro público pero
también concentración sí falta de
diversificación del lado de los pasivos
los depositantes del silicon por ejemplo
edad principalmente empresas de la Tech
Y entonces cuando ese ese sector decide
retirar su depósito pues lo hace
masivamente ha sido el más rápido de la
historia que conocemos porque las nuevas
tecnologías las redes sociales etcétera
han funcionado a lleno Y entonces
estamos en un mundo que ha evolucionado
desde 2008 con riesgos con nuevas
comportamientos Y entonces la
reglamentación tiene que adaptarse a
todo eso
para poder manejar mejor los riesgos los
bancos También tienen que evolucionar
frente a las decisiones de su de sus
clientes volvemos en este punto con
Daniela Ordóñez está en dúplex la
economista jefe en Francia de la osborn
economics le pregunto qué tan sólido es
el sistema bancario en su opinión se
puede decir que es un sistema Sólido y
en todo caso mucho más sólido que lo que
era en el 2008 luego de la de la crisis
financiera global efectivamente
Ahora hay una regulación una red regula
Cómo se dice una regulación una
regulación bancaria mucho más fuerte y
una supervisión hecha también por el
Banco Central europeo y por los bancos
centrales nacionales hacia las
instituciones financieras que garantizan
una buena capitalización una relativa
buena
un relativo buen manejo de las
inversiones de tener un equilibrio
financiero que sea sostenible en todo
caso a largo plazo eso no quiere decir
que el sistema bancario
europeo como cualquier sistema bancario
no no puede tener problemas de corto
plazo es decir problemas de liquidez en
que en un momento dado no hay suficiente
liquidez para tal
Por tal o cual razón frente a lo cual el
Banco Central también tiene métodos para
de responder pero en todo caso la el
mensaje Central es decir que sí el
sistema bancario europeo en este momento
es un sistema globalmente sólido en unas
con una situación financiera mucho mejor
Creo que lo que tenía en el 2008 Incluso
en el 2002 luego de la crisis soberana
con una regulación y una supervisión muy
reforzada
sí la salud de los bancos en cuanto a
liquidez y solvencia en Europa es muy
buena según el Banco Central europeo lo
ha dicho en múltiples ocasiones
imaginemos que esto es así no Elizabeth
lo que lo que decía pero el riesgo cero
no existe no existe Es por eso que decía
este principio del
banco es grandes que no podemos dejar
quebrar
implica que los gobiernos las
autoridades la de los bancos tienen que
ayudar después para evitar este fenómeno
de contagioso entonces este este
principio del tubiqel tiene que requiere
o que pide a las autoridades de ayudar
el banco para no
causar un problema sistémico
implique que puede haber
irresponsabilidad de parte puntualmente
de parte de algunos banqueros o de
algunas personas porque el riesgo puede
tomar riesgo hay alguien que me va a dar
liquidez hay alguien que me va que me va
a sostener porque mi tamaño hace que yo
no puedo quebrar si no desencadeno este
efecto dominó Entonces es allí que yo
digo que hay un problema al nivel de
ética de responsabilidad cuando
desatamos el riesgo y quién asuma el
riesgo quien toma el riesgo pues creamos
lo que se llama
un riesgo moral que unos toman el riesgo
otros vienen lo que decía usted cuando
decía que nacionalizamos las pérdidas es
que son las autoridades que vienen a
ayudar porque no podemos permitirnos de
dejar quebrar un banco por tamaño hasta
la fecha yo no conozco ningún caso de
socializar beneficios bancarios
y al fin y al cabo ese es el capitalismo
amigos no que diría que él asumir ese
riesgo no exactamente entonces lo que
digo que hay que tener mucho cuidado con
el tamaño de nuestras instituciones
financieras y a lo mejor hay que
preguntarse hay que hacerse las
preguntas porque cuando Tratamos de
regulación de reglas etcétera de
supervisión tratamos el efecto Pero cuál
es la causa quizás la una de las causas
de una fragilidad es viene del hecho que
tenemos también instituciones muy
grandes pues muchísimas Gracias
Elizabeth Jesús y Daniela nos han dado
muchísimas claves para poder entender yo
al menos ya lo entiendo muchísimo mejor
la quiebra va la crisis bancaria actual
y por lo menos hemos sabido delimitarla
no en su justa medida Muchísimas gracias
a los tres y a todos ustedes esperamos
en Primera Plana la próxima semana
Muchas gracias